hello screen junkies I'm Dan Morel host
of Summer Movie report on screen junkies
plus and this is my spoiler review of
Suicide Squad that's right the second
big DC movie of the years here and I am
going to get deep down into the nitty
gritty talking spoilers so if you want
to hear all of my thoughts on Suicide
Squad and get ready folks cuz there's a
lot of them let's go let's talk Suicide
Squad complete the mission you get time
off your prison sentence fail the
mission you die
anything happens a kind of flag I'll
kill every single one of you
there's your pep talk so that's it what
we some kind of Suicide Squad so let's
begin with what I liked about this movie
and first and foremost it's Will Smith
and Margot Robbie they hired these two
actors because they are extremely
charismatic because the audience's love
them and surprise their the best parts
of the movie Deadshot and Harley Quinn
are the two standout characters in the
movie I loved both of those actors in
those roles I would go see another movie
with those actors maybe just those two
actors in their own movie any day of the
week I also liked Viola Davis is Amanda
Waller I thought she had a great
presence on screen I thought she really
generated a very awesome aura being a
badass and again if there is a Suicide
Squad sequel I'm going to be looking
forward to seeing more of her character
you didn't see as much as I would have
liked in this movie I also think that
there's a lot of fun interaction between
the Suicide Squad members I think the
cast members probably got along great
together and had a great time on set you
could tell that they worked on that
dynamic and when that group is allowed
to just breathe and interact with each
other I thought that they had a good
time unfortunately there's so much other
stuff going on in this movie now I'm
going to talk about a lot of it so I'm
gonna say right up front I don't think
this thing is a full-scale disaster all
the time however when this movie is bad
it is really really bad so before I get
into everything I just want to say up
front
I didn't hate this movie but I didn't
really like it that much either first of
all let's talk about enchantress played
by Cara Delevingne
enchantress was a complete mystery to me
it's right up there for me with Malekith
and the abomination as far as this
completely forgettable lackluster comic
book villains and
so much of the third act and so much of
the character work for some of the
characters is given to the enchantress
that it all falls flat I didn't buy the
action finale of this film and a lot of
it was because I didn't buy The
Enchantress I didn't know what she was
doing she was trying to destroy the
world I guess we saw like three shots of
that I don't know why they went with
such a big action finale when we've seen
it reminded me of the end of Fantastic
Four last year where you have a movie
that's about a team interaction and all
of a sudden it's just a big generic dumb
CGI cartoony action ending so nothing
about The Enchantress worked for me
I don't think Cara Delevingne came off
very well she looked silly a lot of the
end of the movie was her in front of a
green screen just kind of talking like
this I don't know why the Enchantress
had to dance he was kind of popping and
locking a little bit and her brother
whatever her brother was this thing that
it happened is some random guy the CGI
on her brother was pre-2005 CGI it's
some of the worst CGI I've seen in a
blockbuster in years but there are some
other issues with this movie as well I'd
like to take a minute and talk about the
Joker now the Joker was front and center
in the marketing campaign for this movie
I think advertising the Joker as being a
part of this movie is borderline false
advertising because this movie has
nothing to do really at all with the
Joker now Harley Quinn is in it and
Harley Quinn could have been in this
movie you could cut all of her Joker
stuff and this movie would have made
just as much sense I think they included
the Joker because they know that Batman
is big intellectual property and they
wanted another character to help sell
this movie because they were afraid that
Deadshot and Harley Quinn wouldn't be
enough instead they choose to Jam Mad
Love one of the great supervillain
origin stories of all time from Paul
Dini and Bruce Timm into three to four
minutes of unconnected flashbacks into
the middle of the Suicide Squad movie
that it doesn't really have a place in
to begin with it also doesn't help that
I was not a fan of this portrayal of the
Joker Jared Leto seemed like a high
school actor trying to be Heath Ledger
trying to be a gangster I hope this is
not our Batman Joker because this was a
Juggalo cur I did not like this Joker at
all I don't want to see more of this
Joker I don't know why this is so hyped
that Jared Leto got so into character to
play this Joker he doesn't share
scenes with any other members of the
Suicide Squad I guess Jared Leto can
send dead rats to me and everybody here
at screen junkies it's not going to mean
that I like his version of this
character I thought it was a woefully
misplaced in traduction of him and I
hope that they adjust it for future DC
movies because this version is not
menacing he did not portray menace to me
at any point in this movie and I think
Ben Affleck is going to blow this guy
off the screen if it becomes a Batman vs
Joker duel and that shouldn't be how it
is Batman and the Joker should be equals
right now I don't see that happening
let's talk about the two things that are
the film's biggest problems for me which
are tone and structure first of all
let's talk about tone now there's been a
lot of press about the fact that Warner
Brothers supposedly went into reshoots
after Batman V Superman to give Suicide
Squad more humor to lighten up the tone
because of the negative response to the
dark and grim tone of Batman V Superman
now I don't know if that's true but I
will say that this movie did play like
two completely different movies kind of
jammed and mashed into one together on
the one hand you could see the kind of
darker tone that we saw from the very
first Suicide Squad trailer that was
released you can tell that there is a
much darker version of this movie in
there and I can see why Warner Brothers
would get skittish about the fact that
after Batman V Superman maybe the movie
shouldn't be so dark but here's the
difference this is a movie about
villains if you're going to go dark
go dark if you're going to go bright go
bright but to try to fluctuate back and
forth to make everyone happy to make the
people that want the dark tone happy but
then also the people with the bright
sound happy and mash them all together
it's all over the place I didn't know
how to react to certain moments in this
movie because the tone was wildly
fluctuating but that's not even the
biggest part of the problem let's talk
about structure now if you've watched my
reviews before you know that I have a
little bit of a stickler for structure
it takes me out of a movie if a story
doesn't have an intelligible through
line and much like Batman V Superman
again Warner Brothers has delivered a
movie that doesn't have a solid
structure it's a mishmash of flashbacks
pop song montages poorly set up action
set-pieces it was again a random
collection of scenes and maybe this has
to do with the reshoots inserted
seemingly at random in the middle of the
movie their flashbacks inserted an hour
in the movie
their flashbacks inserted an
hour-and-a-half into the movie their
flashbacks inserted 15 to 20 minutes
from the end of the movie and their
inclusion doesn't make sense it doesn't
make sense for those flashbacks to be
where they are when you're trying to jam
the backstory of the Joker and Harley
Quinn and Deadshot and Captain Boomerang
and all of the other super villains of
this movie into one movie that's what
happens you're rushing things and the
structure becomes herky-jerky because
you have to introduce everybody to all
these characters and still try to tell a
story and I don't think that they told a
very good story the prime example for me
of this whole thing is the character of
katana she walks onto the helicopter and
you just hear I think Joel Kinnaman
voice just go careful boys she's
carrying a sword that'll steal your soul
if she kills you with it
I would advise not get killed by her her
sword traps the souls of its victims by
the way she doesn't steal anybody's soul
with the sword in the movie so they set
up this power they never use it to the
rest of the movie and then at the end
before the big action finale again it
cuts her with the sword and they say
don't worry she's talking to her dead
husband she had an enemy who killed him
with it before she got it what are you
talking about the idea of someone with
the katana blade that will steal your
soul with there she kills you with it
who has a backstory that she stole it
from an enemy who killed her husband and
her husband's soul is inside that sword
that's a badass movie on its own just
like the Joker and Harley Quinn would be
a great movie on its own just like
Deadshot would be a great movie on its
own but it seems like Warner Brothers is
insistent that to sell movies to the
maximum possible audience they're going
to take as many characters as they can
put them into as few movies as they can
try to structure the story as best they
can and shove it into theaters before
it's ready we now have a sample size of
these DC EU movies we have Man of Steel
we have Batman V Superman and we have
Suicide Squad and it's obvious to me
that the current priority at Warner
Brothers is to make movies that make
cool-looking trailers is to make movies
that give these iconic characters
cool-looking frames to operate in but
that's story is a very low priority for
them and for some people that's enough
and I understand that if it's enough for
a Batman V Superman movie where the
characters look cool or a Suicide Squad
movie where Harley Quinn and Deadshot
look cool
I understand that and it is cool to see
these characters painted onto the screen
in a very beautiful and energetic way
but I have been a comic book fan since I
was a kid and what made me fall in love
with these characters isn't the way that
they look it was the stories that are
told with them I referenced mad love
with Harley Quinn and the Joker it
painted such a vivid picture of Harley
Quinn and her sad and tragic obsession
with the Joker the fact that he would
discard her at a moment's notice even at
11 years old I understood what a tragic
love story that was when they did the
death of Superman the way that that was
portrayed and painted and the weight in
half they gave that story seeing Lois
and Jimmy powerless to help their friend
was powerful for me even as a kid and
still powerful for me as an adult reign
of the Superman which I always wanted to
see a movie but apparently won't be one
is one of my favorite comic book
storylines of all times because it's
about identity and it's about the power
of grief and how much people want
somebody they've lost to come back and
how they're willing to put their trust
in people that might not be the best and
most trustworthy people in the world for
the sake of hope these aren't just
stories that look cool these are stories
that have something to say and that's
what these Warner Brothers DC EU movies
for me don't have they look great but
they don't have much to say and if they
decide to continue to discard the
mythology and the story of these
characters that's fine
they're still making money but they're
going to have to get used to critics and
fans giving them grief because that's
what we love about these characters it's
not their looks it's their stories and
if Warner Brothers decides to embrace
those stories to go back to formula and
really decide and figure out what people
love about these characters and bring
that to the screen in addition to the
amazing visuals to the directorial
styles that they already have I think
that they will be surprised at the
success that they get so what did you
think of Suicide Squad was it better
than Batman V Superman didn't disappoint
you let me know in the comments section
below I'd love to hear what you think
and as the summer wraps up don't forget
to catch me every Monday morning on
summer movie report on screen junkies
plus we'll be covering Suicide Squad and
we'll be winding down the summer talking
about all the summer blockbusters a lot
of hits and a lot of misses
we'll be here all the way through August
to bring you up to date on that thanks
for watching this review of Suicide
Squad I am Dan Moreau
see you next time get ready for the
battle of the century between critics
and fans that had the movie's most rabid
supporters sending out death threats
while its harshest critics refuse to
admit that anything about it was cool
even though you'd be lying you thought
this was an awesome
and this wasn't ridiculous hey Martha